Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for joining us for our 123rd episode!
It's a big number!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much FUWAMOCO for joining us for our 1, 2, 3 episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm about to explain a little bit about FUWAMOCO Morning for those of us
For those that are joining us for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Yeah!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, every time there's so much hashtag, hashtag!
What are you doing, Hai?
BAU BAU!
I guess it's okay, maybe.
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
End of the week.
End of the week?
Something special?
Ruffians, I have a question!
What do you like to do at the end of a busy week?
Wait before going into the weekend!
You like to curl up underneath a blanket?
Sleep, sleep, sleep.
Aside from sleep.
Sleep unconsciously.
You like to work out?
That's good too!
Cry.
Cry?
That's good I guess.
Sometimes it's important to cry.
Watch FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
We're going into another fun weekend!
BAU!
We have some bad news.
I said it was gonna be a fun weekend.
Why does it have to stop at bad?
Bad news first.
BAU BAU.
There was another Pero Sighting.
Okay, let's just get it over with, Moco-chan.
Well... Here he is.
De-den!
He looks especially nasty here.
Did you eat all the ice cream you've been stockpiling through the summer and left nothing for Pero to enjoy?
Is that why he looks extra nasty?
I think so.
That's what you did, huh?
I guess that makes sense.
You know, summer is how you want to eat the ice cream, but... Pero... Pero gets really nasty over sweets, okay?
Maybe throw... You could throw maybe something in there for him to enjoy and then conveniently just kind of decide that now's a good time to clean out the refrigerator.
Yeah!
Right!
Yeah, maybe throw in a pretty...
And then pull the plug.
It is really important to make sure that the refrigerator is all clean.
That you're able to enjoy nice and fresh ice cream.
Even during the winter.
I get kind of nasty when the ice doesn't taste very good either.
A lot more nasty than Pero, yeah.
Do your best.
Make sure it's nice and clean and then you can only enjoy some good ice cream in the winter.
Yeah!
Good ice is important.
BAU BAU!
It's not quite winter, yeah.
Ruffians!
You know that FUWAMOCO, we've been a little busy here.
But!
Within all of that, there's been some more voice packs released!
BAU BAU!
First, we have our back to school voice pack!
Our back to school voice pack here, Ruffians!
How many Ruffians are just back to school, huh?
It's kind of a rough time of year, you know?
Summertime was so much fun!
We did so many things, and then... Back to the books.
To a new place, you know?
Gakusei sanshou.
Don't cry!
The training was rough too.
Right!
You know, if you want to go back to school, together with FUWAMOCO!
This is for you!
Yeah!
You know... You graduated already?
Well!
If you want to experience it again.
Back to school brings back!
You know, maybe you could help out FUWAMOCO here!
As I try to do some studying for my math, you know...
Yeah.
Help FUWAMOCO this school a little bit.
If it's with FUWAMOCO then... Why?
You're just starting.
Good luck!
Please check it out.
Hopefully maybe it has this alternate effect that it makes you want to even study harder.
Yeah.
Although I'm sure you're already studying hard.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Don't overdo it, okay?
BAU BAU!
And just freshly released today, we have the four types of extreme love.
Okay, off the top of your head right now, what are the four types of love, Hoshi?
What is it?
Tell me, explain, okay?
And you can't answer Koyori-senpai, Kaede-senpai, Shiori Ayame-senpai, okay?
There's a lot of types of love.
At least FUWAMOCO-
FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO Is this really the taste of love?
Oh!
I see a lot!
I think you might be right!
BAU BAU!
What's your best answer then, Moco-chan?
Romantic love.
Familiar love.
Friendship love.
That's such a pretty action!
Yeah!
She is good, right!
I thought about like the, what about, you know, the love that you feel towards like, your waifu.
Is this regular love?
Does it fall into the pet love category?
I don't know.
I think so, yes.
Sounds legit, yeah!
That falls into the category.
But this is extreme love.
Extreme love!
What do you think FUWAMOCO could be, huh?
Extreme love.
Wow!
The answer is... Yandere.
Here you can listen too!
Yandere FUWAMOCO you know.
And we did our best to listen to Ruffians!
Because you know your eyes, your ears, they're only FUWAMOCO's you know!
Please take a listen, okay?
I want to listen to ASMR.
No!
This is Yandere!
Yeah.
Oh, the voice acting was really good!
Yeah, we did well!
We always work really, really hard on the voice parts, so please give them a shot.
I know some of our fans are surprised, but we've actually participated in every single voice part since we debuted, so... We're always doing our best!
Please check it out!
Fuwawa's scary, Mococo's super cute!
Fuwamoco's scary!
FUWAMOCO is scary.
You know them all, Bijou!
We're always doing our best, you know.
And hopefully we can grow into even bigger grown dogs, alright?
But here's some more voice parts.
No, not what you want!
We're talking about back to school!
The yandere voice.
Yeah, please give it a try someday!
What is scary?
Why are you super cute?
Actually, Moco-chan's yandere is pretty rare, right?
I don't think so.
No!
Yandere isn't really keeping the smile safe, but I get it!
Really?
It's keeping the smile safe.
BAU BAU!
Please listen, you can find it on the official hololive shop!
Okay, maybe there's some Ruffians out there.
Okay, but where do I go now?
Speaking of the hololive official shop, Ruffians!
Thank you so much just recently!
Our first anniversary merchandise!
Thank you for all your pre-orders!
Pre-orders have now officially closed since then, but thank you so much!
I know there's a lot of Ruffians saying like, I got extra glasses!
I got extra voice keychains!
Thank you!
I'm so excited for you to get your paws on them soon, Ruffians!
Please look forward to them!
But also right now, Ruffians!
I think I've been seeing on Twitter there's some Ruffians that they've been getting their FUWAMOCO birthday merch finally!
Thank you for waiting a long time!
I think this means that all the Ruffians everywhere have received their birthday merch!
Hopefully!
Except no issues.
But the first and most important thing is that you get your paws on the Ruffians!
In a few days!
Soon!
I'm looking forward to it!
You have yours!
No issues!
That was great!
I'm glad, thank you!
More important that it's in your paw.
Yes!
You have 10 Ruffians!
That's a lot of Ruffians.
Oh my gosh.
But right now Ruffians!
You know there's been a lot of merchandise coming out.
But right now still for pre-order is our 3D debut!
3D showcase!
Yeah!
You know there's so many exciting things that you might have forgotten about them.
They are currently still on pre-order.
I'm free until September 24th.
So, a few weeks from now, but please don't forget about them.
Especially if you want Mococo's tail keychain!
It says a fluffy fabric, but I think that also means fuzzy, right?
It's fuzzy, okay?
It's not fluffy.
Got it.
Please don't miss it, Ruffians!
Especially, you know, if you're working on that masterpiece FUWAMOCO Itanbei!
Yeah, they'll be super duper cute!
And you know,
This is actually FUWAMOCO's brains.
We wanted to make this because we thought it would be cute.
And then this way too, I think you know in 3D when we're here like this sometimes it's kind of hard to see our tails.
But I think it kind of shows just how surprising the difference of our tails is a lot.
So if you want to be reminded, maybe if you want to be able to
I think I forgot to order Pokey.
And if you're back at school, actually Pokey might be very good.
Because Pokey is made of a pillow you can put your arms on and rest on the desk.
Very, very handy.
Just lock him in your locker like the cell.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I know it's a little bit overwhelming, huh?
Very overwhelming.
That's right, you know.
We try to share what's still available and what's maybe going away soon.
We need our FUWAMOCO moichikai right!
Good luck Ruffians, you know.
And thank you always too.
Wow!
For more exciting news!
Maybe not so related to the hololive official shop, but still exciting if you like, well, cute things.
Maybe singing?
Bowling and video games!
FUWAMOCO!
We're gonna be at FUWAMOCO Round1!
BAU BAU!
All Round1 locations around the USA and Japan!
Yeah!
That's over 50 locations in the US and over 100 in Japan!
And look right there with Ayu-senpai, Ina-senpai, Fubuki-senpai, Okayu-senpai, and Gura-senpai!
Look at us!
We're all so cute!
Yeah!
And this event will be starting very soon!
Starting in October and running into January so... Right!
It's pretty long!
Right!
That means that you can go all the way to Round1!
Three months!
FUWAMOCO Hi!
Super duper cute stuff.
I think your loader has around one foot.
So please go and check it out.
Have FUWAMOCO done bowling before?
Ruffians, what do you think?
Do you think we are pros?
What do you think?
How do you think we do our bowling?
Nope.
I think we did a little bit better than when we played with Wasame-senpai.
Wasame-senpai.
That was rough.
I also almost tossed the controller at the screen.
But I think we did a little bit better than that.
Well, if you want to challenge us at bowling, maybe Round1 might be a good place to do that, huh?
Well, when it comes to singing, you know, we'd be a little bit more passionate and more confident, huh?
Considering we're idols and not boys.
Oh, and I think I saw a comment asking what Round1 is.
Entertainment Station.
Velvet Boy.
Arcade Games.
Howl Gear.
Super duper fun!
So please go ahead and head over to the nearest Round1 to check it out.
Starting October 11th!
Yeah, not too early.
Don't get too excited quite yet.
Please look forward to more FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, now it's officially September.
And well, summer is sort of starting to end.
Yeah.
Obviously had a bunch of things going on, you know.
Our first anniversary, our 3D debuts, Breaking Dementia!
But also!
Also, there was the whole summer bingo!
Bingo!
Yeah!
You know, Ruffians!
There was maybe a FUWAMOCO Morning and that was a little bit funny.
Uh, a bunch of different things, you know, but... She's a bit flirty!
We did our best!
We participated in the holosummer bingo for the very first time!
We filled out the normal bingo sheet.
We did the infernal bingo!
We did everything!
We completed it all!
Yes!
We played a prank on Biboo!
Yup!
We ate bugs.
We made her eat bugs.
There's a lot of bugs.
We had a FUWAMOCO maid cafe!
We caught bugs!
Yeah!
Uh, you know we did everything and anything!
We had very good luck.
More than anything, Ruffians, we hope you had a fun time together with us.
On the left paw.
Wow.
FUWAMOCO!
We happen to be the only hololive members that completed all their bingos.
Both bingos.
The Inferno bingo too.
And didn't win a single prize.
Not even close.
Not many members completed everything.
So I think we should have... What's the word?
No.
Pity?
We've definitely been pity.
We should hold our heads high!
We did it all!
Yeah!
You know!
Just in for FUWAMOCO's consolation prize!
Wow!
We will definitely be enjoying our bunch of eye-warmers, face masks, bath salts!
Yeah!
But more than that, you know, Ruffians, it's not about winning prizes.
We weren't doing it to win prizes.
We weren't doing it to have fun.
You know?
So, I think you know, I know, Marine-senpai, Senpai, Poruru-oneechan, they're like, how FUWAMOCO I feel so bad for them!
But, that's not why we are doing it.
We're doing it for the memories, the journey.
You know?
So... We wanted to do it together.
Yeah.
And I think we're able to do just that, Ruffians!
So we're gonna enjoy the consolation prizes that I think are very amazing.
You know, Brighton used the eye masks all the time too!
Bath salts too!
Special ones!
You know we're gonna enjoy those!
Enjoy the memories we made all together!
And we're gonna do our best next year too!
Next year's hololive summer big!
Maybe we didn't have luck this time.
But maybe that just means the luck is waiting for us in other ways.
So in case stuff like this happens, it's okay.
It'll come around.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, we're just charging up the luck.
Exactly.
BAU BAU!
Another really happy day happened, Ruffians!
You know how we just released our original song, Born to be "BAU"DOL☆★, right?
Right, right, right.
You listened to it, right?
Thank you, Ruffians.
It just recently got over 500,000 listens on YouTube here.
If you haven't checked it out, please check it out.
And it's very cute.
It's also on Spotify.
But!
Now, you can also sing Born to be "BAU"DOL☆★ at Karaoke!
"BAU"DOL is now in Joysound Karaoke!
And also there, oh I see something else.
hololive English -Advent-.
Sirens as well!
As well as Mikocchi-san.
But you know, we always really wanted to have a song at Karaoke!
And now this means that Ruffians, when you go to Karaoke, or maybe when you come to Japan, you're like, I'm gonna go to Karaoke!
You can go at the same point, and we bottle up!
Yeah, heck yeah!
Heck yeah!
Make sure though that you request Joy-san.
Some places have multiple systems, so make sure if you're going to karaoke that it's Joy-san.
Joy-san!
Don't wait for sure, you can BAU BAU lots of those.
Yes!
Yeah.
I love going to karaoke.
It's so much fun!
It's been a little while, but the last time we went was pretty memorable.
We went with some hololive English members.
Yeah, you can be a FUWAMOCO at karaoke!
Exactly!
Too embarrassing!
Okay, you sing Mococo's part, okay?
Not too embarrassing!
Too much fun, okay?
Don't let embarrassment keep you from having fun, okay?
It's important.
Yeah.
I don't know, that's...
That's not how I want to live my life, you know?
Let's live the best life we can, FUWAMOCO.
Without regrets, okay?
No regrets.
BAU BAU!
You can sing it all yourself, so... That might be kind of tricky, but... You can do it!
The FUWAMOCO Challenge.
Mama!
Wow!
Let's take a look at our Doggie of the Day today!
Our Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Enzo!
He's so cute and happy puppy!
Enzo reminds me of me because he's so fluffy and active and happy!
BAU BAU!
I'm honored!
I hope Enzo stays fluffy and happy forever and ever.
She looks a bit fuzzy though, huh?
Moco-chan, you feel a little bit left out?
Look, it's his team expression.
Let's see.
Wow!
I'm Enzo!
Yeah!
How does Enzo BAU BAU?
It looks sort of like...
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Okay, Moco-chan.
I think we can all tell, but Enzo!
Enzo's the best puppy you could ever wish for.
I know, you can see here he's always happy.
He loves to make you happy too.
I think life is really exciting for him.
Look!
He's like, yes!
Today is exciting!
Today is Friday!
Yes!
Tomorrow is Saturday.
And we're gonna go for walks every day.
Yes!
Yeah.
But more than anything, Enzo just can't wait to spend every day together with you.
And also, very important, Enzo's very fluffy.
Super fluffy.
And I think that's super great.
BAU BAU!
He does look like he just heard some good news.
Why?
That's Enzo every day, all the time.
The good news is that he sees you in front of him.
BAU BAU!
For today, I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
That's a perfect FUWAMOCO sky.
Yeah, with the Ruffians too!
We're so happy to hear that you got up for a good walk nice and early in the day.
Exercise right after you wake up is always really good for you.
The Ruffians along with you.
It's good to have company.
It has been so much fun.
I can just smell the cool air.
I can feel it on my skin.
I hope you had a wonderful time!
Thank you for sharing!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And next for our Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
Oh!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
After you open pre-chat, what are you usually doing during that time before stream?
Getting more homework done?
Taking a quick nap?
Watching pre-chat shenanigans?
Or maybe something else?
We are go-go-going still.
Yeah, you know, getting everything prepared.
Our Barker's getting
Wake up!
Grabbing tea and responding to anything from Morning Chat.
Every single moment is accounted for.
Every minute.
Definitely no naps!
No time for that!
No!
It takes a lot of time to prepare for things.
I think, you know Ruffians, it's kinda hard to understand unless you do it yourself.
But we're always doing our best and that does take time.
So for us, the last hour before stream, it's never ever just relaxed free time.
No.
Yeah.
It'll be nice, but... No, at that point we are mad dashing.
Every last moment, every last second.
We know by what minute what needs to be done.
Yeah.
And if not... Yeah.
No Ruffians, thank you for always being here!
We're happy to be able to share your mornings with you!
BAU BAU!
I'm Ruffians!
I want to say another big thank you so much for all your submissions!
Please use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING right at the top there to send us your questions!
Your Pero Sightings if you see him.
Being nasty or grumpy.
Finish your walks.
And you know, you're Doggie of the Day too!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And for our next theme, we have... De-den!
Day 7!
Of Earth 6?
Seven Numbers of ENigmatic Recollection!
We're reaching, you know, the end of ENigmatic Recollection.
The grand finale is within sight!
And I think there's even more crazy things going on!
Maybe like you were saying, shonan again.
We'll see just what's going on next in ENigmatic Recollection!
BAU BAU!
Time for our schedule!
The big finale is on Saturday!
Saturday at 7pm PT.
But after that, on Sunday, we're gonna go take a look and watch all day 1 and day 2 of Breaking the Mansions!
So Ruffians!
Maybe get some popcorn!
Maybe some ice cream!
Penlight!
Apple because it's at the Big Apple!
And also your streaming ticket!
And let's re-enjoy!
Re-break!
The dimensions!
And let's break the dimensions all together!
We'll have lots of secrets!
We have a lot to say!
A lot to talk about!
And we might get a little emotional.
BAU BAU!
Fuwawafians are joining us today through the Archive!
Here is your FUWAMOCO list!
It's BAU BAU yagere!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you so much for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Dear BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!